let's tell the listener at home or the  watcher uh in their in their probably  home or office uh who we have on the  line here if you if you haven't guessed  the voice  you guys it's the star of the of your  television show uh the only woman the  the one and only  uh the big bird herself and um  i'm here and i'm happy to be here  television's katelyn olsen people  salvation's gone  what about the very first time you came  into the audition room uh what do you  remember from that experience did you  you've done instantly do you even  remember rob in the room  no so what i do remember is as soon as i  got in my car i called my manager  because i thought it was such a good i  wanted it so bad and i was like i think  that was really good and she goes were  any of them cute and i was like not  really  [Music]